I promise you [__] an album you've
been patiently waiting now today is
finally present I took my time with the
[__] I put my mind into every line cuz
when inside I'm trying to regret it
[__] get overhyped and all that hits
girls I know that you like to like when
you come to a city man I know that
you're really big on interacting with
your fans just kind of really not you
guys is following but you guys kind of I
want to say you guys are taking the
being close with your fans approach to
another place no one has ever taken it
yeah but you know you like I heard that
you like reached out to fans going
kicked it at their cribs game you can
play skate at you know I know the last
tour you played skate I can't be sitting
with someone right yeah yeah hopefully
tonight up right so is there ever been
an experience where like maybe like some
weird [__] popped with a fan or like you
got yourself into like a weird situation
like like like a violent situation so
much no no no like like I don't know
like well maybe you're just kicking it
with a family that kind of weird
oh yeah usually gets weird when I meet a
fan I go to your house and they'll be so
bring homies over and they all start
sniffing cocaine oh yeah [__] that and
I'm like again alright Google I've never
been like I mean I know people who do
drugs like that but I'm never around it
- whereas like hey they're just right
there snort lines in this chair
something like you want some like no man
and it's like whoa
you to be on my own sick [__]
really do this like this is real yeah
loser wasn't mad yeah they do everything
because my fans do everything so I'm
glad I can some least the most time now
me that they'll stop doing right
whatever just don't try to be so
grounded
why did someone be themselves but
sometimes fans live pretend they skate
and they'll they'll they'll pray they're
bored and they suck they don't even
skate it like me think it's one thing
when a hangout they like they just want
me to be able to sec I just [__]
skinhead I'm sorry Tommy home whatever
song yeah this isn't this fantasy right
stuff girls say the wildest it's me
invited me to their houses to have
orgies wow it's weird she he's a [__]
horrible a trapper he's wack period no
way around it he is wack in the dick in
the dictionary wack it's gonna say this
like Emma Davies these to me he's the
best rapper of all time